melun fait sombrer pendant toute la
journée dégustation animations
folkloriques concert depuis quelques
années les ventes augmentent et le brie
de melun et même aujourd'hui exporter
jusqu'au canada benoit deux buts l'air
anne-christine vote
voilà un fromage qui revient de loin il
y a quelques années il n'y restait qu'un
seul producteur de brie de melun
aujourd'hui 105 de la production est
modeste 300 tonnes contre 7 minutes pour
son grand frère le brie de meaux
pourtant lemelin du caractère trop peut
être pour le consommateur standard de
pâte molle pasteurisé c'est vrai aussi
qu'il coûte cher sans frank qui doit
létale dans un moulin il ya beaucoup de
lait et beaucoup de travail
alors fromage comme ça ça peut être aux
alentours de 4 kilos et jacques ont bien
vite de la 14e' de l'aide d'un bris
demeure le prix du moulin est en fait
due à plusieurs facteurs déjà il ya
beaucoup de lait ensuite c'est un
fromage qui est l'homme à fabriquer l'on
affiné et qui est difficile à réussir
donc il ya de la perte à l'affinage
donc c'est en fait tous ces facteurs qui
déterminent le prix final du fromage pas
question de tuer le goût du moulin pour
en faire un produit de grande
consommation le syndicat de
l'appellation paris au contraire sur
l'autre sens si fier il veut renforcer
en plan les conditions imposées aux
producteurs de l'eau ça des concerts
mais il est nécessaire et quand même
dernier un cahier des charges plus
précis niveau de la race
des animaux parce qu'il ya certaines
races qui sont plus propices que
d'autres pour la fabrication du fromage
et puis aussi au niveau de la qualité du
lait droite romantique et de
l'alimentation
une politique qui ne fait pas
l'unanimité jean claude le seul
producteur à faire du fromage avec son
propre lait je restais libre du choix de
ses vaches et leur alimentation
je pense que c'est plus un problème de
communication coproduction et ses ondes
ont plutôt aux consommateurs d'apprendre
apprécié l'appellation contrôlée telle
qu'elle est plutôt que le contraire
donc je pense que ça dommage d'être
obligé de changer le produit pour
pouvoir le vendre mieux vendre et faire
connaître le terroir sur ce point là
tout le monde est d'accord c'est
pourquoi les producteurs se retrouvent
aujourd'hui pour célébrer leur fromage